من السريه والغموض لافتات تحذير اجهزه
مراقبه وكاميرات وحراسه مشدده على مدار
الساعه
هنا في الصحراء نيفات في الولايات المتحده
والتحديدا فوق بحيره جروم الجافه تقع
واحده من اكثر المناطق غموضا في العالم
انها المنطقه 51
اقيمت المنطقه 51 ابان الحرب البارده بين
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد السوفيتي كما
كان الاختبار والتحديث الطائرات ورغم
افتتاحها عام
1955 الا ان وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه
لم تقر بوجودها رسميا الا في اغسطس عام
2013 وبعد مرور اربعه اشهر من اعلان سي اي
اي اصبح باراك اوباما اول رئيس امريكي
يتحدث علنا عن المنطقه 51
في حول ما يجري في المنطقه 51 ورغم ندره
المعلومات الرئيسيه يعتقد ان الجيش
الامريكي لا يزال يستخدم تلك المنطقه في
تحديث الطائرات الجديده وان نحو
1000 شخص يعملون هناك
ويقال ايضا ان الموقع يضم بعضا من احدث
برامج التجسس عالميا لكن بعض الروايات
ذهبت الى ابعد من ذلك بكثير روايات كثيره
قالت ان المنطقه 51 تستضيف مركبه فضائيه
واجسام طيارها بعد ان تحطمت بهم في منطقه
عام
ويزعم كثيرون انهم راوا اجساما طائره
مجهوله تحوم فوق او على مقربه من الموقع
وان الحكومه تستخدم المنشاه لاختبار اجسام
طائره مجهوله
اليوم عاد الجدول حول المنطقه 51 خصوصا مع
ظهور عده اجسام طائره مجهوله في اجواء
امريكا وكندا
اكد ان مقاتله من طراز اف 16
اسقطت جسما مجهولا حلق بالقرب من مواقع
عسكريه
حساسه وتكرر الامر ذاته في اجواء مقاطعه
فيما قالت وسائل اعلام امريكيه ان احد
الجسمين ثماني الاضلاع وله السلاسل تتدلى
منه الامر الذي اضاف مزيدا من الغموض هو
خروج جنرال كبير في سلاح الجو الامريكي
ليؤكد عدم استبعاد فرضيه وجود كيانات
فضائيه والاستعداد الكامل لبلاده لمواجهه
اي تحديد
عده رؤساء للولايات المتحده تهرب من
الاجابه عن اسئله تتوقع اكتشاف كائنات
فضائيه ولم يفصحوا حتى اليوم عما يجري
هناك في المنطقه 51 سريه فهل هناك علاقه
بين هذين الملفين الغامضين وهل ستتكشف بعض
الحقائق خلال الايام المقبله